ich gehe echt nicht gerne einkaufen und
entscheidet am liebsten super spontan
was ich am tag erst dann zu frühstücken
wollte ich noch käse ich habe halt auch
echten den leeren kühlschrank
link wo wie oder gorillas sind da für
mich die vermeintlich perfekte lösung
die online lieferdienste die bringen wir
einen kompletten supermarkt einkauf
direkt nach hause und das innerhalb von
zehn oder 15 minuten
ich mache das aber trotzdem super selten
einmal weiß natürlich auch teurer ist
und zum anderen weil ich irgendwie ein
schlechtes gewissen habe das kann auch
für die fahrer in nicht cool sein und
außerdem gab es bei gorillas sogar schon
streiks denn das geschäftsmodell als
solches ist eigentlich nur dann
erfolgreich wenn der wettbewerb
ausgeschaltet wird und die preise erhöht
werden können das ist dann aber wenig
nachhaltig und wird in der regel zu
lasten der zulieferer und farben ich
persönlich fand eigentlich ganz gut also
die arbeitsbedingungen von den dingen
lieber kurieren die ich kenne die sind
ausgesprochen schlecht ich will wissen
wie sehr geht meine bequemlichkeit auf
die kosten der mitarbeitenden und muss
sich beim bestellen ein schlechtes
gewissen haben das klären wir innerhalb
der nächsten zehn minuten denn dann soll
meine bestellung da sein
[Musik]
bestellt ihr bei gorillas flink oder
gummi habt ihr dabei ein schlechtes
gewissen warum oder warum nicht schreibt
das mal unten in die kommentare als
erstes spreche ich mit einem ehemaligen
kurierfahrer marcel hat im sommer für
zwei monate bei dem lieferdienste flink
gearbeitet
20 stunden die woche für zehn euro 50
pro stunde
also eigentlich von den leuten her
ich habe nie probleme mit den
mitarbeitern auch nicht
beschäftigt uns dann auch nicht und ich
fand das alles eigentlich ziemlich gut
flink ist einer von mehreren
lebensmittel lieferdiensten dies vor
allem in den städten gibt es gibt auch
gorillas groovy oder geht ihr die
funktionieren alle ähnlich man bestellt
per app seien einkauf und bekommt ihn
fix vorbeigebracht egal bei welchem
wetter das geht weil die anbieter in den
städten verteilt viele kleine lager
haben wenn die bestellung eingeht wird
dort die tasche gepackt und der kurier
fährt mit seinem fahrrad los die branche
boomt vor allem in den städten sehe ich
immer mehr von den kurierfahrer innen
und das belegen auch zahlen im online
handel legte der bereich der
lebensmittel 2020 am stärksten zu und
das obwohl die supermärkte trotz coroner
lockdown immer offen hatten der online-
lebensmittelhandel konnte von 2009 10
auf 2020 eine umsatzsteigerung von 67,2
prozent verbuchen dieser trend lässt
auch im jahr 2021 nicht nach dass die
neuen lebensmittel kuriere schnell
wachsen hat auch marcel gemerkt
hast du ein beispiele für dinge die
nicht gut gelaufen sind
bei uns keine klimaanlagen hatten wo ist
dann doch etwas wärmer wurde das wird
dann aber nachdem wir es mal
angesprochen haben die man vielleicht
hier sagen bewusst und dann auch gemacht
dann kam tim anlagen bei uns im ganzen
laden und dann immer mal wieder mit den
fahrrädern dass das gespann dann halt
nur abnutzungs dinge so was wie bremsen
ging nicht um die seite gestellt massa
hat aufgehört lebensmittel zu liefern
weil er jetzt einen besseren job machen
kann sagt der macht ihm mehr spaß und
der ist auch weniger stressig von
krassen missständen hat er mir jetzt
nicht berichtet anders ist das bei
mitarbeitenden von gorillas dort gab es
zuletzt wilde streiks eine gruppe
kurierfahrer in berlin bemängelte zum
beispiel dass gehälter unpünktlich
gezahlt wurden die rucksäcke sehr schwer
und räder kaputt sein und ein vorwurf
man behindere sie bei der gründung eines
betriebsrats ich habe google um eine
stellungnahme zu der kritik gebeten und
in ihrer antwort verweist die
presseabteilung auf den aktionsplan für
rider das ist ein maßnahmenkatalog der
auf grundlage von feedback der
mitarbeitenden entstanden sein soll
darin heißt es unter anderem es gäbe
jetzt gewichts anzeigetafeln in den
lagern kleinere rucksäcke und ein neues
schicht planungs tool zur vermeidung von
zahlungs des krebses und die trinkgeld
optionen der app wurde von vier euro auf
zehn euro erhöht mit den plänen das
limit ganz zu streichen also es tut sich
etwas die unternehmen die justieren nach
wenn es kritik gibt ob das reicht das
frage ich jetzt eine arbeitsrechtlerin
andrea schneider der hält vorträge zum
thema plattform ökonomie digitalisierung
und arbeitsrecht wie bewerten sie diese
entwicklung wenn beschäftigte
belegschaft mit der leitung mit der
unternehmensleitung in gespräche treten
um zu sagen das sind unsere missstände
und das waren ja aus gebessert haben
aber wissen sie wenn wir rein nach dem
deutschen arbeitsrecht gehen habe
unglaublich viele tolle instrumentarien
die wirklich den beschäftigten und den
arbeitnehmerinnen jemand in ihrem land
helfen sollen wir haben nur ein großes
problem beim arbeitsrecht und das nennt
sich das nennt man in fachkreisen das
ist das vollzugsdefizit
wenn sie niemanden haben der dann am
ende meine wegen kriegen sie an diese
rechte nehme mal an alles läuft super
und sie kriegen all das was sie wollen
wer überprüft ob es tatsächlich
durchgesetzt wird überprüft ob die leute
tatsächlich vernünftig ihre stunden
abgerechnet bekommen ob sie tatsächlich
vernünftige ausrüstung arbeitszeit ein
gehalt der seite all das was wir uns
hier schon in einem programm
hineingeschrieben haben wer überprüft
dass das könnte beispielsweise ein
betriebsrat überprüfen wenn es also
entsprechende gremien wenn es nämlich
dann das ist das was hilft sie brauchen
durchsetzungsmechanismen für diese
sachen und zwar niedrigschwelligen genau
das fordern die mitarbeitenden bei
gorillas sie wollen sich
gewerkschaftlich organisieren und einen
betriebsrat gründen sie wären die ersten
im bereich der neuen lebensmittel
kuriere die wahl aber verzögert sich
seit wochen der wahlvorstand wirft dem
management von gorillas vor man
behindere sie dabei so bemängelt die
gewerkschaft verdi die mitglieder des
wahlvorstands berät gegenüber business
insider unter anderem dem ausschuss
seien nicht wie vom gesetz
vorgeschrieben
räumlichkeiten und arbeitsmittel zur
verfügung gestellt worden gorillas
widerspricht diesen vorwürfen auf meine
anfrage in dem statement heißt es wir
haben den prozess der betriebsrats
bildung mit den uns möglichen mitteln
unterstützt und uns kooperativ gezeigt
mein habe räumlichkeiten bereit gestellt
und dem wahlvorstand unterstützt trotz
aller streitigkeiten laut gründerszene
soll die betriebsratswahl nun ende
november stattfinden auch bei flinc gibt
es keinen betriebsrat eine gründung läge
in den händen der beschäftigten sagt mir
ein sprecher er teilt auf meine frage ob
man denn eine gründung unterstützen
würde mit unsere mitarbeiter verfügen
über jedes recht ihre beteiligung im
unternehmen zu organisieren
aktuell gibt es jedoch keinen
klassischen betriebsrat das
geschäftsmodell der lebensmittel kuriere
ist nicht neu und die kritik daran auch
nicht flink oder gorillas funktionieren
wie lieferando oder ubs sind
dienstleistungen die über plattformen
also zum beispiel apps organisiert
werden auch für essenslieferungen und
taxifahrten gab es anfangs viele
verschiedene anbieter und diskussionen
um die arbeitsbedingungen
dort biss ein unternehmen den markt für
sich gewinnen konnte so wird es wohl
auch bei den lebensmittellieferanten
laufen der soziologe dominik ihr tron
forscht zu diesem geschäftsmodell das
auf plattformen basiert geht dieser
wettbewerb zu lasten der arbeitnehmer im
ja einerseits machen die plattformen den
konsum effizienter das heißt sie haben
eine einfache nutzeroberfläche und sie
bedienen die bequemlichkeit der
konsumentinnen man kann sagen das
smartphone wird zum supermarkt in der
hosentasche auf der anderen seite wäre
das schnelle wachstum dieser plattform
aber nicht ohne die unmengen an
risikokapital zu erklären die von
investoren dar einfließen das heißt die
meisten der plattform schreiben noch
immer rote zahlen sie haben sehr kleine
margen und dennoch investieren die
investoren milliarden von dollar in die
start ups mit der hoffnung dass diese
dann den markt langfristig
monopolisieren und dann aufgrund ihrer
marktmacht die margen erhöhen können das
heißt die das geschäftsmodell als
solches ist eigentlich nur dann
erfolgreich wenn der wettbewerb
ausgeschaltet wird und die preise erhöht
werden können das ist dann aber wenig
nachhaltig und geht in der regel zu
lasten der zulieferer und fahrerin ich
will noch von ihm wissen ob ich als
kundin wegen dieser arbeitsbedingungen
ein schlechtes gewissen haben muss unser
einfluss als konsumenten hängt stark vom
geldbeutel und von der bedürftigkeit
das heißt für die uni von nebenan die
nicht alleine einkaufen kann niemand
anderes hat die die ihr das essen
liefern für die mag das geschäftsmodell
an sich gut sein wenn ich aber selber
zum supermarkt laufen kann dann muss ich
auch nicht unbedingt eine plattform
unterstützen die schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen fördert das heißt da
haben wir als konsumenten durchaus eine
verantwortung wenngleich die
verantwortung nicht nur bei den
konsumenten sondern auch bei der politik
liegt um den missbrauch hier effektiv zu
bekämpfen braucht es wirklich neue
rechtliche mindeststandards für
plattform arbeit mit professionellen
arbeitsschutz mit an wegen
arbeitsverträgen und mit echter
betrieblicher mitbestimmung
ich denke das ist ein wichtiger punkt
denn diese art von neuen digitalen jobs
die wird es ja weiter geben ich frage
beide expertinnen was sie dazu sagen
dass die fahrer in den job doch
freiwillig machen beide verweisen darauf
dass nicht alle studis sind die den job
für eine begrenzte zeit nebenher machen
für viele die zum beispiel kein deutsch
sprechen oder keine andere ausbildung
haben sind diese jobs eine einfache
möglichkeit auf dem arbeitsmarkt fuß zu
fassen nun wann immer sie jemanden
finden der bereit ist diese arbeit zu
machen seien die arbeitsbedingungen auch
noch so schlecht einfach weil der mensch
nur mal davon lebt dann wird es ein
wachsendes digitales prekariat geben und
das ist die dunkle seite der
digitalisierung weil vieles an der
digitalisierung ist ganz wunderbar ich
möchte auch sehr viele annehmlichkeiten
nicht mehr verzichten und es geht ihnen
sicherlich nicht anders und vielen
anderen menschen auch dass es gut und
richtig und dass es viel freiheit
bedeutet auch gut aber es ist eben die
freiheit von uns versus die unfreiheit
derjenigen die zu solchen bedingungen
arbeiten müssen und das kann nicht
richtig sein
hi
vermeintliche raus wollte es war schon
ein gestresster aus flink oder gorillas
sind nun mal junge schnell wachsende
unternehmen da ist klar dass ich am
anfang noch einiges zurecht rütteln muss
aber es gibt ja schon viele unternehmen
im bereich der plattform ökonomie also
zeit dass es bessere standards gibt für
die arbeitsbedingungen und jetzt zu
meinem gewissen nach den gesprächen weiß
ich dass die arbeitsbedingungen nicht
überall gleich sind und es für manche
tatsächlich ein guter job ist aber
insgesamt muss ich in diesem bereich auf
jeden fall noch einiges verbessern und
solange das nicht der fall ist kann ich
dort mit keinem guten gewissen bestellen
[Musik]